as we prepare to honor those who have
made the ultimate sacrifice Memorial Day
will be looking a little different this
year as many stay home and practice
social distancing joining us now to talk
about this is Veterans Affairs Secretary
Robert Wilkie Mr Wilkie thank you so
much for joining us today
really appreciate it but before we start
to talk about how we commemorate
Memorial Dedlock like to talk about
something that happened within the last
24 hours in a back and forth between
your department and Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer it came to light
that approximately 1,300 veterans have
been treated with hydroxychloroquine and
I'd like to put up a statement that
Senator Schumer gave in response to this
he said quote we need to know what the
basis was for using this drug against
the consensus of science which called
into question its effectiveness in
treating covin 19 we also need to know
who is authorizing these new trials what
facilities are participating and what
families are being told secretary Wilkie
I'd like to give you an opportunity here
to respond there this first question who
did authorize these new trials and
should there be concerned sure well let
me take a step back with the the Senate
Democratic leader I think he's trying to
divert attention he knows better than
anyone that we use this drug on a daily
basis 42,000 doses a day we use the drug
in coordination with guidance that we
receive from FDA and Senator Schumer
voted for the right to try Act
which is underlying all of our efforts
when it comes to doing everything that
we can to save life and prolong life we
do that we do this we've used this drug
in conjunction not only with the FDA but
our doctors in conjunction with families
and and veterans we're doing everything
that we can to try to preserve life and
we follow guidelines the other thing I
would also note is that on on the day I
was on Fox a few weeks ago Senator
Schumer's own governor the governor of
New York was asking the president the
United States for tens of thousands of
doses and I also want to note for
Senator Schumer that he is conveniently
skipping a lot of facts in this
argument at the same time that he has
been silent in seven languages about the
thousands and thousands of deaths that
have occurred in his own backyard
because of mismanagement of nursing
homes so I I want to put this in the
context of someone trying to deflect
attention from what is going on in one's
own backyard do you have an update on
the 1,300 just big picture how things
have gone well we've used this drug
normally we have used it as a last last
effort to keep people alive what those
studies did not investigate with the
underlying medical conditions that these
veterans were facing in the original
report we use this in the last hours of
a veterans life in the hopes that it
could prolong that life and again if
you've been in the military or you've
been in VA since 1955 we've all used it
we know it's side effects and as with
any drug even aspirin there will be
someone who has a negative reaction to
that drug but we are going to continue
to work under FDA guidelines that's the
science and I would also note that dr.
Fauci himself someone I sit with in the
National coronavirus Task Force is
conducting the same kinds of trials in
his Institute that we are okay and just
before we run out of time I really want
to make sure we talk about this weekend
and the importance of Memorial Day and
it's looking so different this weekend
can you explain what's being done well
we've never closed our cemeteries Alicia
all 142 are open the only difference is
that we haven't allowed large groups of
people to come celebrate we issued a
joint statement with our friends and the
Boy Scouts who are usually out there
planting flags they will be tied into
our veterans Legacy Project which all of
our veterans in our cemeteries have a
biography on our on our website at three
o'clock on Memorial Day they will all be
in their uniforms standing at attention
listening to a bugler blow taps we'll
have the flags out but it'll be our
people people putting them down
and we asked people to remember that the
American the American Warrior is a
unique unique person in history the only
warrior in history who's offered a
helping hand not only to the people he's
bound to serve but to the enemies that
he fought and I think that's a legacy
that all Americans can be proud of it's
so easy to forget the real reason for
the day so many folks get caught up in
their barbeques and enjoying the
sunshine and all of that but it really
is important it's a solemn day an
important day and I really want to make
sure that everyone knows that on Monday
Youth Secretary Wilkie will preside over
the wreath laying at Quantico National
Cemetery in Virginia on Memorial Day we
really appreciate your time and hope
folks do remember thank you Lisa
thank you thank you for reminding people
what Memorial Day is about